This is Radiolab. I'm Jad and I'm Robert.
Today's program is about sleep as in the kind of sleep where you pretend to
dream. Exactly. Do you know that story about the um, the benzine molecule?
No. Speaking of dreams. Hmm? Well yeah,
here [inaudible] 1865 German chemist is trying to figure out the shape of this
molecule. Benzine,
he knows that has a certain amount of one kind of Adam and a certain amount of
another, but he can't figure out how they all link up. Right.
And he's tortured by this problem. Ghosts sleep. Yeah.
Has a dream of a snake biting it's tail wakes up,
bolts right up and says it's a rain. It's a real,
do you believe that? I want to, well yeah, I mean don't get me wrong.
I hate it when people tell me that dreams hate it. I want to stab up
my eye with a fork. And frankly, when people tell me that, I don't know why,
I never had to tell you about my dreams again, I'm good.
But you know you're not alone because for a long time scientists have have
avoided studying dreams cause they think they're so random and meaningless and
unsuitable. Right. But we did meet a guy, I'm Bob Stick Gold,
S. T. I. C. K. G. O. L. D.
I'm an associate professor of psychiatry at Harvard Medical School.
Who found an interesting way to ask the question, why do we dream?
Simple question. Very hard answer. Robert.
Stick gold was one of the first modern scientists to take dreams seriously.
And for him it'd be actually began kind of by accident.
I had been up in Vermont,
that's my family. We had gone and climbed camel's Hump,
one of the higher easy to climb mountains in Vermont.
We'd gone at eight in the morning.
We were back at two in the afternoon and for that whole day he'd been up
climbing on the rocks, gripping them with his hands, really climbing.
Later that night I lie down, I close my eyes
[inaudible]
I can feel the rocks under my hands
and I started startle all up and I said, well that's really bizarre.
It wasn't like I was thinking about it. I was there. I could feel the rock
had been off the mountain for eight hours, nothing like that had happened.
I lie down in bed for three minutes, starting to go to sleep and boom,
it's there and I tried again and I fell asleep. Two hours later I wake up,
I have to go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom. I come back and I say,
that was way cool. I have to try that again.
[inaudible]
wow,
I cannot get it back.
What happened in those two hours to those memories that they won't intrude
anymore? And then I started talking to friends and they say, oh,
try try to Lewin or someone else says, try, try Whitewater rafting.
If you want to get that and someone else's, oh, hello.
Take organic chemistry and you go to bed at night and all you see are these
bloody molecules rotating in front of your eyes.
Those daytime activities are affecting your dreams and that guiding thinking,
what exactly is the connection between what do during the day
and what you dream at night? What are the rules of that? He figured, all right,
well this replay is kind of interesting. Maybe I'll test it,
but how if I get some subjects together,
what could I have them do during the day that would reliably end up in their
dreams?
But you can't have them all go for a hike and I'm probably not going to get
permission to take them Whitewater rafting. Too expensive. So what could he do?
Sort of set fallow for a year.
And I was moaning from some of my students about how I can't think of how to do
this. And someone says tetris
and somebody else says, absolutely
[inaudible].
I'm saying, what? What? He say, well don't you play Tetris? And I say, yes.
Well when you start playing Tetris
[inaudible]
is that when you start playing touches
you go to bed at night,
you lie down in bed and you see tetris pieces falling down in front of your
eyes. Sure, absolutely. Your eyeballs, you guys both know that?
Oh yeah.
I got a cover of Science magazine for the first published paper and dreaming in
40 years because I discovered that and everybody already knew it.
[inaudible]
it was that simple. He got a bunch of people, put them in a room,
had him play tetris.
Later that night they woke up and 60% of them were dreaming of Tetris.
60% how do you know that?
I mean just from their report as they're falling asleep or monitoring them
electro physiologically and as they start to drift off to sleep. Please report.
Now I'm
filming
this tetris observation was a pretty good start in terms of getting at that
question, why do we dream? Why we dream? How does it work?
What if as a next step, instead of having the people report their own dreams,
waking them up and doing that whole thing,
what if instead you could cut the person out of the equation entirely and go
right to the source, to the dream directly? Matt Wilson,
I'm a researcher here at MIT and I'm a neuroscientist studying,
learning and memory. That's what Matt Wilson does.
It takes us to the dream. Last night when we first come in,
what we see is this bank of monitors, 13 monitors all in a row,
each monitor displaying ongoing activity in the brain, little panels,
each panel, uh, showing these, it's like the Kennedy Space Center.
Really all the monitors have data just flashing all over them.
Graphs and squiggly lines and numbers.
It's not immediately clear where all this information is coming from,
but if you peek around the back,
you'll see that all the computer wires go to one box,
which then connects to a cable,
which then goes up to the ceiling over to a wall and down into the head to the
head generated of one sitting tiny red areas. Yes.
It's just kind of hanging out in his little basket so you can just resting.
Is that the Little Guy Himself? Yeah,
he looks pretty normal except for this take cable coming out of his skull and
the cable is basically a microphone or a bunch of them,
which Matt uses to ease drop on the brain cells inside the rat's head as they
chit chat and this is what that sounds like.
Okay.
You can hear this kind of snap, crackle, pop sound.
These are individual cells that are firing.
Sure.
There one of those kind of whooshing sound.
I can tell this animals sitting resting quietly.
Amazingly. He says as well, he has his back to the animal.
He is so fluent with the Morris Code language of the rat's brain sales.
He doesn't even have to actually look at the animal to know what it's doing.
You can just instantly decode all of that snapping,
kind of like that guy in the matrix. That ball guy, I don't even see the code.
All I see is bon Brunette redhead. Just by listening.
Matt knows when the animal is sitting, he knows when it is sleeping.
He knows when it's running around and amaze even can tell which direction it's
running. That as we were studying these patterns while the animal ran around.
After the experiments, the animals would, they would get tired.
They would go to sleep. I would be there in the room,
but I would continue to listen to the activity.
You notice how it's gotten silent? Yeah.
I begin to notice that when the animals were asleep,
the brain cells weren't just firing randomly. In fact,
when animals would go into rem sleep,
okay,
now he isn't going into rem right now. The pattern of activity here,
notice if it's not these whooshes anymore sounded very much like the pattern
that the animal had just been running through.
If you weren't watching the animal, you would think, oh,
animal has gotten up and is running around again.
But then you turn and you look at, you see the animal is asleep.
He checked the data and it wasn't simply that the rat was running around in its
mind while his body was asleep. It seemed to be running a specific route,
the same route in fact that it had run earlier in the day. Same sequence,
same order, same everything. Yes, it was rerunning its maze,
step for step. So then he asked the next question,
are they seeing the things that they saw while they were awake?
We can actually look into these questions as a rat. So the answers, the answers,
we see evidence of replay and basically all of the parts of the brain that we
have looked in, they see the maze that they ran through the very same maze. Yes.
So that is dreaming in a sense. They are, how do we define dreaming?
So sounds like dreaming to me. I don't know. I mean,
but the question remains why would the rat or any creature do this?
And so Matt came up with a simple next experiment.
He decided to give the rat to mazes.
What would that do to its dreams of the night or whatever you want to call them
if they run on maze number one. And then on May as number two,
we see them running maze one in maize two together in a way that they did not
experience when they were awake.
Oh. So it's like a remix and new patterns alludes part of Phase One and part of
phase two. It turns out that when the Rad had more than one maze in its memory,
it began to invent completely new mazes.
Gives us the thought that
sleep is this unique opportunity to basically run through events,
to put them together in ways that may not have occurred while the animals were
awake. And that's what learning really is.
Learning is about synthesis,
about taking things that were apparently unrelated and figuring out the
connection that is figuring out the rules, the hidden rules,
the undiscovered rules that will allow us to create something new.
I think dreaming is a time when we try out possibilities that in waking we might
not feel were worth trying and when it really works,
it can be profoundly important if Robert's to gold is right.
And how does this solving the problem thing, how does it work?
How does the brain decide what to put into a dream and what to leave out of the
dream?
One of the interesting things about dreams is that people don't have dreams
where their word processing, where they're surfing the net,
these things that they spent huge amounts of their day doing don't get into
their dreams, but somehow tetris gets in there every time we die.
And why would that be? Well, he has a hunch,
which he's actually exploring with a completely different video game.
We've moved to a game called Alpine racer, which we bought out of a arcade.
She showed us, took us down the hall to uh, to the game room.
Here we are and they're in the corner. Each stood mockingly.
Oh Wow. It's a full body game. Please step up. I stepped up to the game, right?
It's trying to lock itself. It's still warming up.
And then I set off down a virtual mountain.
Alright, I'm going down the hill. I'm also a girl.
I'm also avoiding the skis for what I'm doing. Take a nice little turn there.
Be careful of the little wall straight down the head and down we go. Oh No, no.
The tree [inaudible] we're not going to go through the tunnel.
This is a wow. Oh, that hurt. As you can hear,
this game was really stressful, I would say, which is by design.
Robert stickle has the theory that as you go through your day,
your brain is constantly keeping track of emotions. That's the thing.
Emotional content, like when you run into a virtual tree, for example,
your brain is going to flag that stuff. It's going to flag that is important.
It says, Ooh, I need to remember this so I can work on it later.
I'm going to put a sticky on this one,
so if it puts a sticky on everything that's hard during the day,
then all the brain has to do when it's creating a dream is go and grab sticks.
Oh, I didn't. I died, but I died. Nice. Okay.
Okay. Just for the record, you've got further than jet on your first try.
Oh Wow. Wow. It's like the Tober.
Could you say that again?
So you have people play Alpine racer for 45 minute bursts throughout the day.
What happens next? You wake them up, monitor their brain
activities,
and just as they're falling asleep within the first two minutes after they fall
asleep, well, wake them up.
There's a microphone right next to them in their bed and they just report what
was going through their minds. I was just thinking about skiing,
skiing.
Can we get on the first night up to 40% of all the reports being about skiing
and the game that I've been playing. Okay. Ski Racer, again,
40% almost half of them. And that's right up there.
What I would expect to see after trauma where something has been labeled so
intensely that the brain says, okay,
it's obvious what's on the agenda for tonight.
Steve Gold thinks he's seeing the outline of the dream making process here.
It starts really simply at the very beginning of sleep,
like right after you fall asleep with the replay.
This he suspects is just the brain emptying out at sticky things that really
intrigued me during the day that they felt during the day. Yeah,
but what happened?
And if we let the people go to sleep, sleep two hours,
like I didn't that very first time after climbing the mountain,
wake them up after two hours of sleep.
Cause you remember he couldn't get Mack the memory of the rocks after he'd spent
two hours of sleep. That's right.
And what he's found is that if you fast forward two hours into the dream,
get almost no reports of skiing at all,
the replay seems to dissolve into a remix.
We start getting reports like
alright, jumped. I was sliding down a hill going down hill,
just rolling down a hill on mark about,
it was about this head down hell banana.
I was thinking about skateboarding.
I was thinking about about a bunch of bananas doing, you're the honest caseload.
Someone else had a dream that they were rushing through a forest with their
body, incredibly stiff and their leg is not moving at all as if they were on a
conveyor belt.
It's like as the dream goes on, the brain is starting to free associate.
What do I have in my past that has anything to do with mountains,
anything to do with crashing or skiing, anything at all that can help me.
What do I have in all my memories,
my case from the last 60 years that fits associatively thematically and the
result, well might seem random. It is, but every so often he says,
you come up with the right answer.
So now we get to your dreams of people discovering the structure of benzene.
Cuckold was his name. [inaudible] actually August calculus.
He was a German guy who talked about earlier,
who had a dream of a snake eating its tail and realized from that dream that the
shape of the Benzie molecule is a ring. I don't know if that dream is true,
but maybe that is in fact the point of dreaming.
It's this time when you shut off the outside, turn inside,
take the problems that you've got and start to really work on them,
pull them apart,
make connections that you wouldn't normally make during the day all.
However,
have you ever wondered why it would be necessary when solving problems like this
to dream so vividly?
Are you at all puzzled by the super duper technicolor,
extraordinarily cinematic quality of some of these things?
Because if it were just an everyday brain function to sort of make sense of the
world and allow you to make new connections,
you really wouldn't need quite the the movie quality.
So when we talk about
dreams, what seems to come into dreams are memories,
concepts, relationships,
associations that have a strong emotional flavor and I'm guessing from the data
need a full blown orchestration to be properly processed and it is its technical
or the colors are overwhelming.
So if I hear you right,
what you're saying in Robert's question about why are the dreams so, uh,
vivid is that, I don't know,
but maybe the vividness helps. Okay. Hold long answers.
What a Harvard professor says instead of saying, I don't know.
I guess we should wrap up if you want any more information on anything that you
heard at this hour, visit our website,
radiolab.org you see there'll be more information about sleep on there.
It will there. Yes,
there will be more information on sleep and you can sign up for our podcast
radio lab.org also,
while you had to send us an email radio lab@wnyc.org is the address.
Remember also that sleep spelled backwards is pills,
which is what you do to an orange grapefruit and full pair of jet.
I've been Rod, I remember college. We'll see you later.